prise ce matin à l'annoncé de la
décision des laboratoires russe roussel
de suspendre la distribution de la
pilule ru486 appelée communément la
pilule du lendemain
déjà vendu dans plusieurs pays et est
autorisé à la vente en france depuis le
23 septembre dernier deuxième surprise
la décision du laboratoire n'a rien à
voir avec l'efficacité du produit que
personne ne conteste jean pierre qu'un
sens le ru486 le voici c'est lui dont la
firme roussel vient de suspendre la
commercialisation
trois semaines après sa mise sur le
marché ce renoncement est expliquée par
le laboratoire comme la réponse à
l'émotion d'une partie de l'opinion
publique française et étrangère
de nombreux groupes de pression hostile
à l'avortement ont menacé roussel de
boycotter tous les autres produits du
groupe
si le ru486 continuer à être
commercialisée
les dirigeants de russel n'ont pas voulu
prendre un tel risque financier avec la
suspension du ru486
c'est l'arrêt de la possibilité
d'avorter en absorbant un simple compris
mais bien sûr l'avortement chirurgical
par aspiration demeure ce matin
monseigneur de courtrai président de la
conférence épiscopale a exprimé sa
satisfaction devant une telle décision